we're back with another emergency
episode
oh my god i feel like we're in the
hunger games is it like the hunger games
yeah like i feel like for survival
yeah and you look like the effie oh my
hair well also just
addressing the nation we're like
visiting the nation
is this the um state of address
the state of the union it's so nervous
i'm get so nervous going live because we
were speaking earlier also too it's like
we're not like i don't like you saying i
don't want to be like don't look at us
as like those great beings we're not
like a great being you know like i don't
want people to think like oh we
are a great no everyone's like you guys
need to go live we're not going live to
be like wow look at all this power we
have like i go live because i have a lot
you are a great being
no i agree i don't like what i mean no i
i'm kidding i'm kidding
i thought you're on board no i'm kidding
but i know what you mean
i don't like this whole on the pedestal
thing because i starting to see people
be like
ethan and trisha are the new such and
such it's like
me and trisha are both deeply flat and
i'm i
i hope i'm not speaking out you can say
are deeply flawed
individuals we've again i i'll speak for
myself on this but i've said and done
things
that are horrible that i regret that i
will apologize for as many times as i
need to
but like i just i don't want you guys to
put me on a pedestal
thank you because we are imperfect
people
say i i don't wanna why are you laughing
dan
you need to say something about your
hair oh any further oh oh
you look crazy well as i was saying
about being an imperfect person
i am not just i just no ethan no
on the pedestal [ __ ] i thought you
had a headband in your hair when i first
came in that's why i like what i was
like
okay so well yesterday you were mad at
me for not buzzing my hair so i was like
i got better but
we saw david's apology video last night
this morning at like 1am oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah fellas because
we were all watching it and talking
about it i was like trisha's asleep
she's gonna be buzzing in the morning i
was in midnight i woke up and watched it
and i was like you know you're a little
shovel in the middle and i was so upset
and i was like you know what
maybe in the morning when i feel
different in the morning i just got even
more like upset about it and pissed off
and i was
like yeah i was like i knew you were
going to have a lot to say well because
i was like i probably will make a video
even though i don't
we're this is hopefully mark our words
this last time we talked about because
we i don't like
it i don't want to talk about david it's
like crazy in front of me we look like
we're a david dobrik like
pitchfork account or something we're
just well we've been we've been listen
we've been
the thing is is that it's like every
time there's something new to talk about
it's
i'm not trying to rehash it but it's
like the story keeps developing although
keemstar tried to jump on it last night
we're supposed to talk about him
but don't say we're not supposed to talk
about it
i thought you don't like talking about
him though because even when i bring him
up okay
well he was going live yesterday he was
like in on i was like oh my god is he
coming for our brand
oh you think he was trying to step on
her feet a little bit anyways no i'm
glad people are talking about it
like no i don't i don't care either but
i was just like i thought it was just so
interesting because i watched a little
bit of his life and he's like
we're waiting for david's video to drop
which by the way david in the video said
like no one knows he's making it he's by
himself but like keemstar knew he was
making it like yeah apparently there was
like people like sending out tips
and then jeff texted keemstar that's who
then like jeff
is texting whatever yeah apparently
literally everybody knew somehow that
david was dropping this video but
regardless
i was cutting my hair this morning
because last time you were upset
you looked crazy and then i saw the back
and i was like oh that's pretty epic
you remind me of gypsy rose blanchard do
you know who that is no
but i saw myself in the mirror and i was
like well let's just do this for one
more episode
yeah and i'll cut it off well farrell
zoolander i think you should cosplay him
i think that's a pretty good one let me
see the profile dan
that looks really good kind of because i
shaved the back too it looks skinny
but you shaved it back yourself yeah i
did it i did it all day
it looks good i think but you don't like
the back
it's so awesome you look like a
chihuahua that grows hair in bits and
pieces
i like it it's just crazy but yeah i
thought i'd just give it one last hurrah
i've seen you so much i've seen you
friday sunday monday
we like housemates at this point yeah
literally
we've still got to order pizza let's do
it today okay well
let's just not like i know this is a
serious topic but maybe just to say
mukbang it up in a serious and a way of
being like
we're gonna close the chapter now on
david
i think so i think we were surprised
because you said yesterday in front of
me which aired today
you said that you thought david would
just go silent
i was [ __ ] dead wrong on that one
holy [ __ ] honestly okay
one other thing i'll say is a lot of
people are like okay people are pissed
that he doesn't say anything and then he
does people are pissed but it's like he
should have taken some time i think we
got over the fact that he wasn't gonna
talk about this it's like why don't you
take a few months rather than like a
week to say like i've changed i'm a girl
because like a week ago
he was like discrediting me his lawyers
sent threatening letters to try and stop
the article it's like
you can't have a change of heart that
quickly now all of a sudden you're like
oh i'm not going to discredit yourself
like
five days ago you said i was talking
harassing you like it's okay so let's
get into it maybe take some time
maybe you know take some time to
actually learn first of all i want to
say
jeff who we obviously had on
dude it's been like it's it's been crazy
we had jeff on and we talked about the
last episode which is up today
please watch that episode instead of the
watch both episodes
but anyway i wanted to say that jeff
messaged me
right before we went live and said he
took down his video so i was very happy
to hear about that
so appreciation i think that's a huge
thing that's crazy that's like
because he kept it up thinking like i
feel like he was trying to still get
people but that's that's a pretty big
thing
that he messaged you too i guess he
wasn't pissed that he looked
you know not so great on the front of me
well whatever
the reason he thought about him he took
it down and i
and i think that was a uh thoughtful
thing to do so shout out to jeff
okay yeah we think for sure like he's
probably yeah
even though he should probably took him
down yesterday but we don't we don't
hold that again
it's fine i think you can have a day to
think about it right
right right i'm like david's saying two
years to think about it i think a day is
okay
okay so first of all i have a lot of
stuff
to talk about surrounding david's
apology
before we watch david's apology right
i do want to say that my initial
reaction
to this video last night when i watched
it was that like
this is you know from what i expected
a very good apology but wait you you
said you think it's a very good apology
well my
initial reaction was that like based on
the previous one i was like this is very
genuine
he seems to be affected but there's a
lot of things
there's a lot of issues that i have
so you thought it was genuine that's
interesting
i'm conflicted on it in that
i thought it was i thought it was
as apologies go
a pretty good apology like he said the
right things right
i'm so confused like what because he
literally
like threatened the insider last week to
not post his partner no that's all i'm
saying on face value he had multiple
times to apologize this before
sponsors got lost and he didn't and he
only apologized
i have i have a whole explanation okay
why you think it's not
face value was good but i have a lot of
criticism of it on face value was [ __ ]
it was awful i was just like i like the
cuts the edits he was teary eyed one
minute
well compared to his last one i mean
this one he at least was like
he said your name he said he said he
acknowledged that like
the way he's shooting his videos is
messed up but the circumstance makes it
and disingenuous that's like if you feed
someone dog poop and then the next day
you give him the cat pooping like oh
thank you so much at least it's not dog
poop
because cat poops cats are more up
echelon but let me explain myself better
please but i mean i respect your opinion
but
you're wrong well hold on hold on on
face value because at first when he
posted it
there was like this crazy overwhelming
support firm
like 99.9 like ratio and that disturbed
me
how i persuade you a little bit i guess
no it didn't sway me it disturbed me and
it made me feel like
there was something about it that didn't
stick right so what i was to say
trisha so please don't kill me because i
have a lot here to say
metaphor is that you know this apology
came all within
the short time span of sending the text
messages
and voice notes to scotty to discredit
seth that happened like a week ago like
three weeks probably or wow has it been
though yeah um
right he says in the video guys look at
these texts like it's david's voice
trying to prove that seth is a liar
exactly so there's that by the way he
doesn't mention seth at all still
in the [ __ ] apology video okay um
you know and then like a few days ago he
made this really horrible apology video
where he
evaded any responsibility this is comes
right after sending
threatening legal letters to insider
about you
there was multiple paragraphs saying i
am a danger to them i stop and harass
them
i've been violent towards david which
has never been true like
i mean saying i have a mental illness
all this like using all this stuff
against me and i'm just like
and now he's in this video five days
later he's like i'm not going to
discourage his change
because he lost all the sponsors that's
the only thing that's the only thing
i i think on face value like how
everyone was perceiving it was like this
is a good apology because he did and
said the right things but then when i
thought about it
and all this stuff came together then i
real then
i'm realizing that this was an act of
desperation and not
because like maybe maybe two people like
it you know if i'm if i'm on like the
outside i would probably be like yeah i
guess he's cool now or whatever but
you even said in a tweet that you were
happy that he
took some accountability yeah i was
happy
i think it should have been more yeah no
i was
sleepy and i was you take that back yeah
i take that back i was like
wait a while and also like i agree with
that point you know what i mean like you
didn't learn this overnight
i okay but i'm not even done yeah and he
also says he didn't address these people
in the video like he he's
he like reach out to them first before
we make a video he's apologizing to the
people because he lost sponsors so he's
apologizing to his fans when in reality
ally hardest he said she never had the
girl from that accused of dominant 2017
autograph apology from
david i begged for david to talk to me
for a year and a half because i was like
what the hell did i do wrong and he
ignored me so
like all of this is [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ]
so not only do you send legal letters
attacking you recently
i mean jeff whitake made a video
attacking you and the author
um and after losing every sponsor
ruining his investors have all ditched
on this app everything he's built on
then finally he makes an apology so on
surface love you i mean i'm just trying
to explain
why when you look at the video there's
like a 99.9 where it's ever like
this is a great apology on face value it
feels like a great apology
but in the context of everything that's
happened it's a very opportunistic time
it's yeah like wait if you wanted to be
more genuine wait also i feel like he
should have like
he profited off of people's trauma he
should have donated some of that money
if he was really sorry
he didn't donate like how much money did
you make like just from that video alone
oh my god anything i think that and
seth's videos with the
all the kissing [ __ ] with seth i mean oh
yeah he's made so much money and
um he could have donated like a million
dollars if logan paul could do it back
in the day
like david's way more balling than logan
he could have done a million dollars
easily
to not even say anything that would have
helped to make a big donation of course
like that's like okay maybe because
obviously it hurt when his sponsors left
because of money so that's why so if to
show you're not a greedy little
you know it's live but if you're not a
greedy person donate the money then like
if it's not a big deal if you're losing
money and losing sponsorship that's not
why you're doing this but you actually
want to educate yourself and do better
and help people
say like like such [ __ ] here's a
tweet you made that i wanted to read
just two weeks ago david sent scotty
text trying to discredit says story
last week his lawyer sent four
paragraphs to insider discrediting me in
disgusting details
sorry if i don't buy that he's changed
and wants to hear people out now a few
days of
miraculous turnaround he was so graphic
the letter from the
his lawyer i don't know if it was lawyer
was so graphic and so disgusting and
using everything i've been through
to basically say like you can't take
trisha for she
she's not valid like anything you can't
believe it's like
so now he knows that was [ __ ] up now
he understands
i she'll that was a huge mystery does he
okay no i'm being sarcastic
like i was like being sarcastic and the
scott video like
did he not even want to address that and
be like no again because he just throw
he threw scott
now scott by the way is the biggest
sucker on the planet
because scott was such as lackey to try
he like he was testing the waters with
this discrediting
angle and now david's out here
apologizing for everything and scotty is
like
looking like the biggest [ __ ] fap
ever
and david didn't even try it oh yeah
yeah
um here i'm going to read more your
tweets because that they're good i'm
trying to give as much content as
possible
if public opinion gives david if public
opinion forgives david great i hope he
does change but as someone who has been
shunned ridiculed after my psychotic
breakdown from my association with david
his lawyers discredit me and causing me
cause
caught discrediting my cause because
mental illness threatening insider only
week ago it's not enough
funny how he ignored everyone's call for
years but now he's making himself
available
i think david is disgusting and i always
will he's calculated and manipulative
but good job taking my notes from
enemies and sitting on the floor for
your apology
he didn't do the floor sitting to humble
him which helps
the vibe was right it wasn't like him in
his set like
behind his kid's choice award like hey
look at me
no it wasn't he also i'm alone now
well he also made a very good a point as
he was adjusting the camera to show that
he was in a much smaller house than he
lives and he's in a like an apartment
so he's trying to show more humble
jeffrey started this a week ago with his
apology he also adjusted the camera on a
tripod yeah what is that it's like i
know how to set up a camera and push
play
i believe i'm the one who started this
trend you called it out on e3 you
remember when i was like adjusting
talking about dave portnoy
you are such dude you are such a
trendsetter they're like wow trisha
nobody apologizes like you
they're like if trisha can be well
received now maybe we can by adjusting
the camera showing
everybody else i'm gonna have to
remember that next time
okay guys i'm finally alone
why did he say that as if that's like
something like amazing feat he's like
look guys i'm all alone at 1 45 a.m
like well i'm we're gonna watch it
david's all about the money remember
when logan i see
again i want to talk about logan paul
because during the forest incident
it makes me appreciate logan's apology
so much more
now because when all that went down and
by the way what logan was accused of is
not even close to as bad as what david's
accused of because like
you could be insensitive you could be a
douche which was all the things he was
doing but he didn't commit like a
assault
a crime right like which is kind of what
david did was more
yeah on other people on girls like it
was like this involved so many other
people and not just these girls but like
like other things in the vlogs that he's
filmed over the years you know zayn
groping people all this stuff like that
david's been knowing this for a while
logan did this like effed up thing or
whatever like that but he
went silent for a month like did this
whole like research documentary talk to
like
survivors of donating money all this
stuff and david took a lot like two days
a day after he lost a sponsor in his
and he donated a million bucks logan so
like damn
i'm thinking back to that that was like
a good ass apology what logan did
compared he said you continued uh logan
paul donated millions of suicide
prevention
david dobrik you profit off so many
people's traumas i think 1 million to s
a
charity is a good place yeah i can't
imagine how the victim's essay are
feeling right now to get apology video
instead of a direct contact
that pissed me off i'll tell you why so
i get a text message this morning
my my situation with david and jason
like it was traumatic but it definitely
wasn't
on this like level of these girls
especially because they don't have a
voice they
you know all this [ __ ] like whatever
like they didn't get a direct apology
like i
i couldn't imagine so for me for so many
years not getting a doctor apology like
it traumatized me i was just like oh my
god like these people are like making me
think i'm crazy like they're you know
all this crazy [ __ ] and then
for them not to get i thought that was
like really like shady and for him to
also kind of downplay and be like i
didn't know when you filmed it and you
were standing there with them black out
drunk like
[ __ ] yes and the dom stuff he filmed
with him in 2020 like he just had so
many lies and consistencies and these
people that
had come out with the voice especially
this particular instance they're
probably just like why
didn't you call me why didn't you
apologize to me when i asked you to take
it down or anything you know
he really should have called these
people before yeah that's that was my
point of view because like
he would have got so much more
perspective and on a personal level to
hear them out i mean dude like if he
really cared now he's like i'm gonna
make myself available
okay david what does that mean you can
you call me if you have a problem i'm
available now
i got nothing to do i got some free time
coming up he's gonna set up an hr
for you to talk to yeah you can you can
contact my hr
team he should not get hr his team is
just everyone from he went to high
school with
natalie she edits all his videos with
him she knew about this she did a
statement the other day being like
i don't condone this [ __ ] you edit all
his videos with him like you sit there
with him when i had my issue with david
he's like well natalie said it was okay
to put up bring it up with her like
natalie sits there and edits all this
[ __ ] with him so don't play innocent to
that either i [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ] like it's all
[ __ ]
todd just posting pictures in david's
house 10 million dollars
no i don't think we talked about it on
hold on i gotta pull that up real fast
natalie's boyfriend taught todd what
todd smith
uh todd eric i think todd eric that's
like such the whitest name ever
well i think he is hispanic oh well [ __ ]
me then
but still is the whitest name ever i
don't know what to tell you todd
yeah i think so he posted this like in
the very [ __ ]
middle oh it was a week ago oh that's
what he disabled though but he disabled
comments at david's house they were also
partying with olivia jaden and her
boyfriend over the weekend so they
literally didn't care anyways they were
posting like instagram stories and
they're like we had to take some time to
reflect it's like no you were partying
with olivia jade and her boyfriend
i don't know bro you should all just be
chilling out right now
no and guess what she's back the whole
group was hanging out with her when she
was 17 too i was in one of the vlogs
when she was 17 we went to her house and
laurie laughlin was there and i was like
why are we going to the 17 year old
girl's house like sneaking in her
bedroom it was so
and they hung out with her for a lot of
times after that i'm like this is all
really weird like this girl's 17 like
emma chamberlain with 17 like all this
stuff like don't
they're all shady he has animal abuse he
has to own up to he has other [ __ ] like
this isn't just one thing and like
you're like learning okay before we get
into
donating i saw some great memes
no but you're gonna like this okay girl
gets r-worded
david dobrik says f this i did nothing
wrong you would heal for my lawyers
david dobrik loses sponsors
this is his reaction do you get this
name
yeah i've seen this face meme around
it's for different memes right the space
is used for different memes
it's the the premise of the joke to me
is
do you understand the joke that it's
conveying what is why are you so meme
challenged
i don't get memes we get it without you
having to make a meme about it
it's funny okay i don't like this one
but
bruh is that the only meme no i got more
i think people love watching me try to
explain memes to you like you're my
you know six-year-old aunt thank you who
is do we know him
where have i met him i hate memes
the con let's not forget this was a
great comment on his apology video which
i thought was uh
coming from the community someone said
proud of you david being an
idiot is easy owning up to it is tough
glad you made this
now if you guys don't know that's the
exact comment david left
on dom's video apologizing for what he
did during vidcon
i get that meme good right yeah that
one's like
we found a successful meme that's so
funny
i mean david is just such an idiot he's
just
like and you guys asked me this morning
if like i
like an apology from david or jason it
would mean absolutely nothing to me at
this point like i asked for an apology
it's like it would have been absolutely
nothing this is all just to say face
and he's disgusting i'll always think
it's disgusting and like there's nothing
they can do to change that
there's some tweets that i thought were
were good takes i wanted to
give voice to david dobrik said you
couldn't wrap his head around the fact
that his childhood friend was
a a assaulter and that's literally the
problem men
ignore and discredit women but won't
hold their besties accountable
which by the way did you notice all the
people that have come forward in david's
group the vlog squad have all been
female it's been carly aaron and natalie
no one else scott hasn't said anything
todd zane
like jeff definitely should not have
said anything but like why has no one
and i know guy said anything jason
they just all said scott said something
and jeff
in in support of all right right right
right right right not david so i guess
that supports her tweet but even carly
and aaron and all of them they all like
just go against dom they're like well
dom
is the worst but it's like i know i hate
that like just say david is also part of
the problem that's why that's
that's what they're all that's the
another thing with my videos that he
once again deftly evades the fact
of how culpable he was with this
horrible crime that happened
this was one from our subreddit that i
thought was a really good insight
shout out read it yeah from our i think
it's from our subreddit
i heard they like me over there so they
love you i don't know why they and then
whenever you say something nice there's
always memes of like trisha is what they
say really i gotta get on it i don't
know how to get on reddit but i'll get
on it i'll find it
just a website you know how to use a
website right i like the apps better
right they don't have oh they do okay
i'll figure it out
all right let me read you this this was
i thought again a really good insight
from one of our
users on reddit as a sa survivor myself
this makes me feel defeated and hopeless
a rant in response to his video
as someone who went through essay and
more specifically are
this story felt very personal to me i
could i could see myself in hannah so
many ways because i went through the
same situation of being
assaulted i saw my r word get away with
it no consequences and his friends stood
by him
the fact that everyone is willing to
forgive david after seven minutes
and a few tears despite what he did is
shocking and devastating for me
david knew that dom assaulted ali in
vidcon 2017.
david knew hannah sent that long text
message
describing her assault and he silently
took down the video
and remained friends with don david
kept dom as a friend all these years
knowing what he did
david went as far as to joke about going
to jail that night again what was the
joke
david recorded and monetized someone's
trauma in front of 10 million people
david sent his lawyers to try to
suppress the article as hard as they
could
david sent his friends to try and take
the heat off him
david and his lawyers kept trying to
discredit victims just as recently as
last week
david refused to make any appearance
because he didn't think it was worth it
took every single one of his sponsors
dropping him to make him appear
and make a few minutes of uh make a few
half
and make a few minutes half apology
where he deliberately lied
lies can be easily debunked if you've
been following the situation
i didn't know she was r-worded he did
know he and
all three of his friends went to do a
head count claiming
that if he didn't see it it didn't count
not to mention that he was
fully aware of the alley situation and
decided to suppress it
and praise dom in the comments for his
apology i stopped having contact with
dom in 2019
he was photographed smiling opposing
with dom in february
2020. i actually have more on that
coming up he
which we'll get into later video he had
him in his merch promo for fan joy
like yeah i've got i've got more on that
later
i didn't know there was a power dynamic
he said there's several vlogs where he
mentioned that he is the leader of the
vlog squad and makes people compete for
air time constantly reminding his
friends that they're nothing without him
i don't know if i'm more angry at myself
for watching him from so many years and
not realizing
angry at david's fans for giving him so
easily angry at myself that i projected
my traumas in this situation
he constantly paid people like he knew
he had power over people he always paid
people to do stuff he paid me like
money to one time to suck someone's toe
one time to drink someone's piss like
you'd always give me like a hundred
bucks you drink someone's piss
who's keith i don't know who that is
how much did you drink nobody does
anymore um it was like a water bottle of
it
how much do you pay you 100 bucks trisha
i know crazy
i'd pay you way more to do that i'll do
it
um all he's saying is he knows he has
power over people like even like even
corinna he paid 500 you know and again
i have to often go back to seth's story
because when seth said
you have to remove this video of me it's
kind of like affecting my life and my
mental health
he offered to pay him so i don't act
like he didn't know about influencing
out over people
she finishes by saying at the end of the
day i just hope hannah can find closure
and i hope that she can move on
peacefully with her life because i
didn't and it still haunts me every day
so thank you for sharing your story to
this person on the subreddit
you know yeah it's it's really bad this
story is really bad because you know the
pr
the thing is he'll of course he'll be
fine and you know he'll continue to do
whatever he's doing it's like
just like michael bay and like all those
people like they all just continue
working brian singer like people do
horrible things there's like evil people
gibson
like people still work like yeah and i
mean those well
mike mel gibson again it's like he said
anti-semitic things but like he didn't
like still this is kind of even worse
i know but that's what i'm saying is
like he's still gonna just be able to
that's why i was disturbed when i saw
99.9
likes i was like really everybody's down
with this i don't know
it takes time though maybe over time
like eventually kind of like kevin
spacey like it took a while for him to
actually get
canceled cancelled you know because
those there were so many stories about
him for so long and people just kind of
knew
do you think there's a road to
redemption for david like years from now
if he makes meaningful changes well i
don't i don't think he deserves it but
of course he will be able to you know he
has a fan base and he's
i see i don't i don't know that i i
think that there is
a legitimate path to redemption for
david in
in some time i think he's super evil i
think it's
but i don't know him i don't know him
like you do so i only know from what i
experienced and that is like a really
traumatic thing he knew that i like try
to kill myself jason do that and like
they literally just blocked and ignored
me and then not only that but you
weaponized it against me even jeff up
until that
on sunday being like well you did do
this two three years ago so how are we
supposed to hold you credible like
they use that constantly his lawyers all
this stuff like that like a really
vulnerable thing that like
came from there from trump because that
week that week up to the
the thing of me doing that like i i told
david i do not want the stuff in the
vlog he still put it up
basically he told me natalie said it was
okay deal with her i don't have time to
talk to you and then jason like you know
what i mean they're just so evil they're
so evil in so many ways so manipulative
it took two years for any of this for
him to say my name and for jason call me
and it's like i'm it's like i don't care
anymore like
you guys are so you just lost everything
so now you're trying to get on i think
what they did to you is unforgivable
because like like you said
you went to the hospital like mental
hospital twice as a result
of your time with that three times and
you've never been through that
and with talking with like big nick and
seth and like a lot of people who've
been and
been in that switch it's like there's
something extremely wrong with the
dynamic going on there where people are
being
and for david's lawyer to use what jason
told him about that that
second time that i went to mental
hospital about like going to his house
or whatever
and say that i was dangerous towards
david when david wasn't even there like
that's so that's so messed up to me they
share these stories with each other
and then they make it to like
corroborate this thing that trish is
crazy hear my lawyers go
go go threat insider with this
information like it's so gross it's so
gross and then why even bring me up
yesterday descri
i'm not gonna describe trisha i had
nothing to do with it why would you
discredit me that's such a stupid thing
to say like what was the point of saying
that i was so pissed
they were yeah just up until a week ago
before the article came out they were
literally doing anything in their power
through their attorneys to stop the
publication so
i guarantee you if that article was
never printed there'd be no apology
right now
even though he knew all this [ __ ]
already anyway here's another name
david making a tricia styled video on
the floor crying
so take again pro you
you've got you owe some sincere thank
gratitude to trisha
i was crying over like a breakup he's
crying because he's a little
[ __ ] and there's one last good tweet
here
before we watch um
oh this was an interesting observation i
thought a girl who hangs out with
hoes is automatically a hoe but men who
hang around abusing manipulative
r-word friends and all of a sudden it's
not their business
pick a script and stick to it right
that's more yeah i mean that's like
pretty much all the guys
it's like oh i can only speak for myself
even though you always speak for each
other
we we're a group we know who we are like
you guys always peak in that tent so
which is yeah it's we we and then also
it's like hey i can only speak for
myself
but you didn't you spoke said anyways
that's so annoying so frustrating
okay so ah and then there's one other
thing that i wanted to
it just sucks that so many people are
like buying this like okay yeah you
don't need to keep crucifying him but
like the fact that you're like oh my god
dave is like so good now it's like
he's not good overnight maybe like he
said maybe in time he'll learn i don't
know
years i mean who knows but like
it doesn't happen that quickly like a
change no a couple weeks
yeah yeah from like no he literally had
his lawyer send a letter threatening you
an insider a week ago
and now he's like okay i'm not gonna
discredit anyone it's like i've changed
my mind
anyways like seriously the people are
like
he's such a good person he want to do
this i don't think any lawyer could have
prevented
with the evidence here's the message
from natalie i know you have opinion on
this that's his
you guys know natalie i spent this came
out um let me just come out yesterday
yeah last night
i spent a lot of time thinking about the
recent allegations and because of the
severity it's taken me time to process
like many of you i'm upset and angry and
do not condone the behavior detailed in
the article
or any misconduct abuse for that matter
i want to make it clear they acknowledge
here and support those who came forward
and i stand by the victim
victims
i don't know anything about natalie but
i thought the worst no there's a lot
more about natalie too i spoke to this
girl cassandra who
i won't share her what she told me but i
i i
she has like a ton of stuff about
natalie which i already knew i already
knew and stuff after i left and stuff
like that
natalie is like the worst of us she's
like his producer she produces the
content edits it
she kind of like gets people to like
come into the group and stuff like that
she's really calculated really
manipulated she's a downright [ __ ]
and david put all the all the blame on
her and i totally i
i believe it's half and half he put all
the blame on natalie when my instagram
went down well natalie said i could put
it in well what and i was like well who
the [ __ ] is natalie because
she's just like this slow girl from
illinois
what footage did she say he could put in
it was that week that week of footage i
didn't want the tan a bit like all this
stuff because i was like pretending to
sleep when tana came over
so she said otana or or natalie got
permission from you
no he said he goes i i gave him i said
no do not put it in he put it in
and he's just like oh take it up with
natalie i'm boarding a plane oh cause
natalie sits there and edits it with him
he's like she was their editing it was
totally fine like no
natalie is a [ __ ] she also ignored like
ignored everything she's like the worst
like actually the worst cause she also
like you know she's the one that has
people saying nda she's the one that
corks his people to do stuff and stuff
like that and
i wasn't there for after my i just heard
from what i heard from cassandra like
what happened after i left and like
again their whole like corroborative
plan to prove that like i'm crazy and
like all this like you know all this
like it was it's all [ __ ] but you're
saying natalie is just lame
who's just lame chizzlane maxwell
i don't know what that is yeah we just
talked about it in the last episode
just lane nah never mind oh okay
i like the name oh people are apparently
you let so
j okay the chat is blowing up because
you slipped that jason called
yeah you want to talk about it i mean
it's fine like because he's he's such a
piece of [ __ ] i went on a twitter i went
on a twitter rampage or not rampage
but i went oh by the way the girl that
said she got the unsolicited like
eggplant pick from jason that is real
she actually reached out to me like and
i know this girl has like
limited credibility first of all let me
just preface
i saw this good thing there was a girl
on twitter that said
that jason sent her an unsolicited
eggplant
photo thank you um and this is the same
girl who claimed that kanye and jeffrey
start had an affair
and then she took but she totally lied
but she's also the same girl who mike
maljek did cheat on lana rosewood and he
confirmed it
she gave him a uh sucker punch you know
yeah she was on dr phil too
her name is okay so but so you
corroborate her story
yeah cause this was two years ago she
sent me a screen video recording of it
you id'd
his eggplant um she sent me the snapchat
yeah and she
she she goes you know he made me feel
really uncomfortable this was after we
broke up and i
or and i was just like okay well like if
you're she was 20 she's like a little
age whatever she's just like it's creepy
and or whatever and i was like if you
want to say something like you need to
say it because so many people were
coming to me as they still do just tell
the story and it's like well i'm not
what am i going to say like
don't send 20 year olds your eggplant by
the way no one wants to see your
eggplant that's what i said on twitter
yesterday like i'm going to body shame
him because he's a piece of [ __ ] but his
eggplant is like wrinkly and it's like
nobody wants to see that
why does he think as a 48 year old man
20 year olds want to see it they don't
like not even 20 year olds want to see
21 year old eggplants like it's just
like gross anyways
so i was just like and he has children
and i'm just like what is wrong with
this guy like he's so he's such a piece
of [ __ ]
so tell me what did jason uh say to you
oh and today just like
made me have so much i'm on the phone no
he called
you didn't answer i didn't answer
because i thought maybe it was uh show
the text
please yeah i can show the text so i
saw this text and it pissed me i can't
get in trouble for trying attacks right
no [ __ ] him
how am i going to show it here we'll
just we'll we can just
here i can send it again i'll send
oh you can send me on discord that i can
open it oh cool there you go
well you can't show it to him because he
it's like unsolicited you know
it's not a conversation he's sending you
unsolicited i thought it was actually
someone like you know how you can like
call someone from someone else's phone
like if you know two people's phone
number so i thought it was like a
i'm like well because he called me like
clearly this is a hack then he said like
hey
it's jason okay here's the text
it says jason it has no there's no
private info
in the in the chat or anything no yeah
no there's it there's no phone number
right
no yeah i think we're good yeah good
call good call
so he sent so you he called and called
you didn't answer right
so he sent this hi trish it's dish jason
i tried you are you available to talk
call me back
heart the [ __ ] heart
the balls on this guy to send you a
heart after all this time you're engaged
like what oh i miss you babe like what's
the heart mean who sends a heart for
your
i'm sorry but [ __ ] no [ __ ] heart
jason
i begged and pleaded for jason to beat
my friend to talk to me for david to
talk to me like
and they just like completely blocked me
they knew all my [ __ ] that i was going
through like jason strung me along for
like a couple months after we broke up
or whatever but then like completely
blocked me after my second mental
hospital stay
and i was just like like begged to be my
friend they ignored me for two years
they called me crazy discredited me said
i'm stalking and harassing them
which i've never texted them or anything
like that and i was just like really
like why would i call you back i thought
i'm stalking harassing you
so then i thought well call me back the
heart i'm like okay this is clearly
someone
playing a joke like i thought somebody
hacked his phone or clean you know did
one of those things
um but then he sends me a dm from
instagram
i haven't opened it should i open it
yeah reopen it [ __ ] i mean obviously
he knows we're talking about it now it's
his dick pic
so so it's a blue check mark it's his
account look i'll show you
see it goes to his account so it goes to
his account
hi trish i just tried you not sure if
you still have that number i have the
same number
please call me so we can talk thank you
jason [ __ ] you jason [ __ ] you like are
you
piss you off now knowing that it's like
him yeah i was like
like how dare you send a heart because
that's like a romantic thing like i
like you or like i miss you or i love
you it's like how are you gonna [ __ ]
claim to
to how are you gonna send a [ __ ]
heart when all you've done is just say
i'm crazy you've detailed like our
me coming to your house that night with
people to like weapon like ignoring me
just been
like old friends or some [ __ ] yeah like
with love like
peace and love no peace and love to him
he does not deserve
hate as they say chaos and yeah
creation soldiers say well let's see
peace and love would obviously be war
and war and hate with war and hate no
one disgusts me as much as jason because
he shared so many like private details
of like when we were together after my
mental like break
and he shared it with david clearly jeff
clearly all these people who like used
it against me now and i'm like
yeah is it why is there a picture is
that just from your phone i mean yeah i
just haven't
changed it ever so it's just there okay
got it but
i was like ew and you know what i'm sure
like
now he's losing it too because david's
his cash cow right now that the cash
cow's not being fed
jason needs he doesn't have a teat to
suck on so he's just like oh let me just
grasp for straws
and then texted me hopefully he's
calling to say thank you for saving my
life yeah maybe
maybe that's why he's calling and in
that case i still don't care i still
don't think
i still don't send the [ __ ] heart
the heart is not appropriate so much
like
is it animosity that's so much like
i don't think i've ever like despised or
been more disgusted by someone like stop
hanging out with children
stop sending girls your eggplant pick
nobody wants to see it
like i just wanted to throw up in my
mouth probably the same way they did
when they got that eggplant picked just
stop it
stop being on snapchat stop it oh it's
like you're 48.
and you know what like i've never sent a
dick pic in my life
i mean good no one wants to see nobody
wants to see i don't want to see
anyone's eggplant
i don't want to see oh this isn't
anyone's in a picture that's not
attractive it
doesn't turn me on you can put it in me
if that's what you want to do but don't
i don't want to look at it what am i
supposed to do with it um
okay let's let's let's get back into the
so anyway we're talking about you have
baby hands jason's got baby hands so
then he looks baby eggplant and the baby
hands looks even more baby
hold on that let's just get this clear
size of the hand
um does not correlate with size of the
i agree i'm saying he has both so it
does look like a baby hand holding a
baby
what do you plan um i'll body team like
you want a mental illness
jason did what dan
just the conversation kind of got
sidetracked are you saying trisha that
you saw the evidence that he sent
a dick pic to this girl i saw the upper
hand
because because most people are
dismissing that claim because of that
girl's history
with the jeffree star thing like i've
seen that universally good
right and i get it because when she came
out that sounds like girl what are you
doing but you're saying
it's true yeah i saw the top half she
didn't send me his full thing i saw the
top half and it did look like his
okay so you know his snapchat name and
he doesn't have i don't think he has a
public snapchat
was his snapchat name by the way any
time someone asked to add you on
snapchat he's like a celebrity or older
run
it's not the first time shay car
remember the girl that shay carl did
that webcam thing she also had an affair
or
an encounter with jason and she was like
a 19 year old cam
girl and she sent me stuff too so he
does this this is a pattern like it's
fine they're not illegal it's fine he's
just creepy like yeah but like
hey if that's your thing cool but these
are not these girls things because she
did a whole tweet about it she said this
is me and jason they want to get
starbucks they've
she said it was the worst sex of her
life whatever like jason was the worst
sex of her life yeah her name was oh
whoever had the webcam mistress with
where'd she and carl go
david dober take a note from shay carl
and just you know maybe go start a
family in utah or something
okay we're getting close to watching zoo
apology
but there's a few new things that came
to light that once again i think
offers a good context to the
again just remember how if like if we're
apologizing or forgiving somebody so
quickly we need the full context of what
we're dealing with i'm so pissed off at
these two i
was like it really reignited that i'm
like no like
no you don't get to apologize two years
later because you're losing money like
you were so
gross like you could have picked the
phone like when i was david could have
picked up the phone when i was out of
the physical hospital like he could have
picked up the phone so many times and so
could jason like f you like i was
bawling i was like doing stuff publicly
online to be like can you just talk to
me and tell me what i did wrong like
they're such awful people such awful
people
that's sad i didn't consent to half the
the bits that are in david's vlogs
oh like you want to hear this the shit's
crazy i don't know this one
yeah this one's this one's surprised
from even me
um i'm talking about this yesterday
though that i wanted to talk about
we are our roommate alex okay we have we
have we have this roommate named dom
and he's like he's like [ __ ] like
typical social media influencer
like not the brightest but super hard
working like just like a
he's just a character he's very strange
um and
yesterday it was like three days ago me
and jason were sitting on the couch
and dom was leaving and he's like i'll
see you guys later and
and we're like where are you going they
just finished a story about how um
they they get their dick sucked for
shout outs and then they said that yeah
they were there they were talking about
they're okay let's let's rephrase i
didn't even put this in the vlog
because i thought it was so gross but
one of our friends
one of let's not our friends one of
dom's friends
when girls come up to him he's a big
instagram following
when girls ask him for shout outs he
he tells them okay if you suck my dick
um
i'll shout you out and i'll delete your
shout out as soon as you're done sucking
my dick
and he's done this like six or seven
times yeah and it's amazing right
to me that's like
literally weinstein level [ __ ] that he
thinks is amazing oh yeah
oh he puts out on a pedestal he tries to
act like oh i started seeing it and then
i did this to myself you just himself
because of the pandemic
it was 20 20 you were filming with him
you had there's a vlog on dom's channel
from january 22 and then potentially you
didn't film with anyone
so by that technicality you distance
yourself from everybody like
he's that's he put dom on such a
pedestal it's like it's so
gross and you put him in merch campaigns
after i had left the group he was in
merch campaigns like
you're gross that to me was like a
scream skin crawling [ __ ] there's
another clip that surfaced because i
know everybody is desperate to say oh i
wasn't there that night when it happened
with dom i wasn't there that night right
so this is interesting they're such
liars like i don't know
how do they think this is to me you know
with the photo that we showed in our
last episode with jeff
you know this one is even worse frankly
because it matches up with their outfits
interview
so here's don coming out with a used
condom
the same night right after the
attack happened by the way before
watching it's not as we noted i haven't
heard
from jason since the night i went to his
house when i was high on meth may 8th
2019. so him now
you think now all of a sudden this is
like a genuine thing where he's like you
know what my mission
no of course not okay anyways that's
sorry i'm still just like living about
that just so people know just for
context
he's ignoring me after i try to call him
so many times and i made videos reaching
out to him and stuff like that and he's
ignoring me so i don't i do not believe
i don't think anyone i don't think
anybody does
trust me okay they're kind of more you
know why i flush comments on the toilet
because i'm afraid that girls are going
to take it and impregnate themselves and
i'm trying to get my food
she's trying to get money from you mom
you have an apartment with three
roommates
so again jeff todd
jonah where's this from the vlog
i don't actually know where it's from if
it's from some behind the scenes or
extra or some [ __ ]
but so what's interesting about this is
so this has happened right afterwards
and you know that
because they could they keep trying to
say oh it's filmed on a different day
they're all wearing the same clothes if
you go back to the footage that i showed
in the last
episode of um
of them standing outside dom's apartment
with the girl who's blackout drunk
you'll see which i can match it up for
you guys just as proof
[ __ ] it doesn't that girls are going to
take it and
impregnate themselves and try to get
money trying to get money from you
do you have an apartment with three
roommates okay so here they are
also he's holding his hand a bottle of
pepsi which one of the witnesses
was used to mix drinks okay so now
now if we go ahead and go back to the
photo that we showed in the last episode
you can quite easily tell
that they're all wearing the same outfit
jeff with the hat
todd with the hat uh i'm gonna call him
nick because jonah's like
why are we calling him joan it's [ __ ]
up he's wearing the same hoodie
it's the same night it's the same
[ __ ] night
so you so according to them he left he
was there in the beginning he left he
came back and then went and greeted
but they did they had no idea what was
happening why am i in that picture
where which one oh because it's a
screenshot of our i thought someone was
trying to like incriminate me
yeah oh yeah that clearly looks like you
were there i was like
what i am so it's the screen capture of
our livestream
like photoshopping me and some i was
like oh apparently you can hear the
girls in the background too if you
listen with headphones dan can you hear
it
in the beginning people are saying that
what's your condom
because i'm afraid that girls are going
to take it and impregnate themselves and
try to get
i mean i hear what sounds like a female
voice softly in the background i can't
make out yeah people are saying if you
listen with headphones you can clearly
hear
i'm sure there were i'm sure they were
there so again it's like
let's stop the [ __ ] charade you know
i mean they're all proven liars at this
point
david included being like i believe the
victim you should believe him you filmed
her
you were there yeah like why wouldn't
you so again i
i feel like he's still trying to
conveniently
you know okay but now i'm ready to watch
his actual apology but it's working
people are forgiving him so
so here we go you ready you're that hr
person and will all be better how do we
feel about the title it's um
just the day one interesting
oh is it that's so weird it's a fresh
apology title
i've i've seen that uh that variety
before you have
yeah yeah because i think the the
generic date apology video
that's one of the many genres of apology
videos
right he's trying to avoid being meme
like an apology meme because they always
have like the tier list
my truth yeah i feel what would have
been better is just like the straight up
you know img zero four nine five zero
you know like the little like file that
it is when it's uploaded i did that a
couple times
just the number that's real wrong you
look real wrong you are
you are the queen of apologies trisha
like i just threw this up
you guys minus all the edits and the
jump cuts i'm sure natalie did this for
him but so anyway if you go to his video
so many jump cuts in this there's
probably more dislikes because there's
probably
but like when it first came out it was
like literally less than one percent
i didn't even get that on my best videos
but i'm like hey guys it's just me being
happy and peaceful and
it's like [ __ ] you there's always people
like [ __ ] this content
anyway here's um david's apology
hi guys it's um 1 45
in the morning and i'm finally by myself
which i know doesn't sound that crazy to
be by yourself at 1 45 in the morning
but um
this week's been pretty hectic and there
have been a lot of people
um a lot of people around telling me
what to do giving me advice
trying to help me most importantly and
and that was a lot and and and and now i
i just want to i want to be able to do
this and
so are you a little raspy dan
i i think that's just the quality of the
video he should fire megan the pr girl
because that was the one who told him to
stay quiet in my situation
oh ignore things and things go away
that's what she tells everybody bro
that's not you're not like
if that's your job just telling people
to stay quiet that's epic i want that
job
just no no no just never whatever
happens no no no
don't say anything oh oh my god he makes
me physically sick more than anybody
like i can't even like look at his
little
face let's give him a chance
no what oh okay for the vid we are live
dude let's do it we are reacting
let's do a live reaction even after i've
just spent like basically an hour
saying about what a [ __ ] apologies
but let's be fair i didn't sleep at all
last night i had like severe anxiety i
don't know why like i was just like so
upset like physically sick it was so
weird and really anxious too this whole
thing is just maybe
yeah i know i was saying it's weird it's
like it's such a weird feeling and i
that's why i don't like talking about
him but at the same time like i'm glad
people
are people you know i do hope more
people just like share their stories and
stuff like that because
i hope people can see it's not just two
isolated incidents like this is a
pattern and more things should be talked
about but
do you want to feel my poof no no
i need like a crunchy
scrunchie uh you look curry can we get a
p
should we so should we get a pizza to
like be like okay yeah we should just be
like this
we're done with the david thing right
pizza
someone said they got domino's ads
before this at the live they said there
was a domino's ad
so here's what we need to do before we
get into this um
um i have to message
lina what kind of pizza do you want
actually cheese just cheese i mean what
is wrong with you you always ask me this
remember last time we tried to order
pizza though you say we need dominoes
yeah because last time we tried to get
pizza hut
and you guys ate it without me right
well that was
i didn't want to okay so you want what
i just had a really traumatic moment
first of all and i'm not supposed to eat
and i have like a eating disorder and
i'm not supposed to eat
pizza you have an eating disorder well i
don't know probably i'm not undiagnosed
but like i mean come on i have an issue
you have a
issue with food not an eating disorder i
don't know if it's a disorder
it could be all kind of what kind of
pizza you guys want
any veggie pizza or just the cheese i
can eat cheese too
i like cheese pizza what about olives
and
pineapple and jalapeno get that for
yourself i'll get
okay i'll get i'm gonna get a veggie and
a cheese in that
veggie you let's just get it who wants
veggie veggies so boring i hate like
pepper and onions
literally just said he wants a veggie
pizza yeah but you see he also said he's
good with cheese i'm good with whatever
okay
okay so without without pepperoni or
whatever yeah get more than two
one large cheese one
large veggie okay veggie wow boring
i like a veggie pizza one large
uh pineapple wait what
olive well yeah yeah yeah definitely
that yeah
twos are never enough i never go for a
third piece when i'm
when you get two right yeah i don't want
gil like that's the thing i don't want
guilt
yeah where you're like oh i should save
slices really yeah [ __ ] that
that's how i felt you did that once you
only ordered two pizzas one time and i
was like oh i'm starving when we left
it's like we gotta get more not this
time okay yeah
one large pineapple olive jalapeno stat
and you want the cheesy bread or not
yeah yeah for sure
two of those your favorite pizza is is
cursed man i'm sorry
my favorite pizza no no ethan's oh that
combination like all three of those
ingredients are obama
all three of those ingredients i like
together did you ever try a slice of it
yeah i tried it oh my god we're
literally live people are probably like
okay this is this is compelling content
why does this be live all the time 24
hour live show
have you ever done that i feel like
people used to do that on like you now
remember well people did that like on
big brother or whatever or that i don't
know if was that live
well that's all right let's focus okay
all right back to david
do you think david will call in should
we ask him dm
we do follow each other on twitter yeah
why are you following me well i did i've
been following david since i met him
like
hey judas i don't i don't like did you
imagine if i followed keemstar i was
like hey kim what's up i'm surprised
you're not
maybe i will talk about judas i followed
him for years
before i even knew you you know okay but
now you know me
but now i want to know if he's tweeting
and [ __ ]
doesn't it's not a endorsement following
someone is not you can still see
someone's tweets without following them
just go
look them up it's not an endorsement
it sounds like it's me he unfollowed dom
this morning he
still follows me and i hope he unfollows
you after this
okay come on it follows me actually did
you know that david and jason both
follow me
exactly that's the point you just not
it's not like the whole
the process of unfollowing is very
severe it's very it's like a lot
i unfollowed them okay let's watch just
shoot straight into the camera and just
talk to you guys um i've put myself in a
lot of situations where i needed to cut
it was a jump cut oh
no okay how many times did you do that
it was only like a minute like how do
you need to cut after a minute
like why can't people just do a whole
talk through like well trisha to be fair
i don't know because you will do like a
30 minute video that should be cut to 10
minutes so i'm not sure you're right
ambassador
he has 30 minutes worth of apologizing
to do to people in his vlogs i think
there was more than enough
footage to go with this was
very subpar but okay apologize for my
past actions and i've
never done this correctly and i've never
done this respectfully
and my last video is a testament to that
i i don't want to
defend that video i don't want to delete
that video i just want to be clear
what this video isn't going to be is
it's not going to be me so he's
characterized in the last video just
like oh
it's just a shitty apology that i just
didn't know better but like that was a
way
of he was attempting to avoid
being totally canceled by trying to you
know
uh put all the blame on dom and like
evade it all himself
so i don't know that it's totally honest
just characterize
it as just a bad apology i think he
probably was like okay just like put on
apology we'll see how it goes because
they were like on the fence with it and
then when it didn't work out they're
like
we gotta not do this i'm very like you
know what i'm glad that
sponsor like sponsors are hearing this
you know because these are big brands
and big companies and like you really
want to associate with that what about
chipotle did they ever make a statement
they're sponsoring james charles and
david dobrik
chipotle's they they're that spring
chicken burrito they don't give a [ __ ]
no i think they didn't i send you
something did chipotle
the spring chicken burrito is like
pretty good but it's not
great
maybe the something about um
because you have to put like you have to
put like a food thing in there like a
food reference like a food pun
i'm gonna think the spring chicken is
good it's just i hate hearing it because
it's just kind of disturbing
it's just not a good enough play on
words but it's very accurate
he's so gross like honestly it's just
james yeah don't even give him a start
yeah
we're trying to close the lid on on
david here yeah but i'm saying it took
this long for david to get like
camp cancelled or whatever it's like
james like it'll happen in due time
because you keep doing the same stuff
that people have called him out for like
it's gonna happen
he's just a little more fresher than
david even though he looks like he's 40.
you know the meme with like the grim
reaper going down the hall oh yeah
the doors you think so it's chipotle's
the grim reaper
david oh see you want me to show you the
video
i just can't this is not the mean pocket
all right let me show you the grim
reaper
thank you oh my god i hate memes
oh i can't find a good one all right
let's just watch this yeah let's not
watch
the meme of the group we're discarding
trisha kat or any other woman involved
you said your name what are you texting
me that i was like oh that's let me hear
what he has to say and then that was it
i was like okay thank you for
he still said your name this has nothing
to even do with me i'm like okay
yeah well thank you david for
acknowledging my existence this is what
i've been waiting for my whole two years
i saw a really funny comment was like
david saying trisha's name confirms that
they
that the two you see that dan i'm gonna
[ __ ] murder it but it's like
exists in the same universe big if true
because you know how people
speculate like if different heroes exist
in the same way oh
yeah who's the hero am i a hero yeah
you're a hero and he's a hero and he
mentions your name so it's like
oh it's the same we're like the avengers
[Music]
um that may trigger some survivors and
that's just so i don't explain anything
vaguely
and i can explain every situation
appropriately i want to start this video
off by saying i fully believe the woman
who came out against dom and said she
was
i know because i was there and i filmed
it and
she gave me consent the next day and
then she didn't give me consent
obviously like i know i wasn't i don't i
don't know
i i do have to be honest here i doubt
that he knew the severity of what
happened
but when he received the text message of
her six
months ago he definitely stopping you
right there i know for a fact
i will say this because i've always said
truth because i know i could get sued if
i didn't say the truth this is the truth
people can back me up that were there
david asked jason to go
buy the girl's alcohol jason or david
never puts anything on his credit card
ever not even dinner or nothing
he has jason to do it this is when i
said to jason don't you freaking do that
what the hell these girls are saying no
whatever
and he did ask people to buy alcohol for
girls why else would you buy alcohol for
girls when you're trying to have them
have sex with your friend
if it's if it's not for them to have sex
with your friend like he knew the
severity of it
like he knew like how unless they're
just so stupid and think that's how
everybody does everyone just gets girls
drunk to have sex with them like i don't
know like these it was there jeff said
that alcohol was there jeff said alcohol
i guess what i mean is he didn't know
that like
the the the extent to
which the assault took place behind
closing that's [ __ ]
because they saw them having sex oh i
don't care what jeff says oh we acted it
out he
david corroborated two days later saying
yeah it didn't happen unless we thought
like they saw they don't do that like
they don't fake things in the blog like
that people but
he was in ours while hearing us have sex
like he doesn't he doesn't have
boundaries like that like he saw
he knew it the girls were drunk and that
is considered our work you're right if
if what you're a violent r word or
whatever but well come on we don't need
we don't even need to mince no but
what amazon i think he doesn't think
it's an r word thing unless it's like
violent a lot of guys don't think that
they think
unless a girl has bruises on her then no
this is also when you
get consent because you're incoherent
that's also the r word and he knows that
he's filmed so many people drunk
including me including things like that
you don't you can't consent to a clip
and they can't consent later
that's not consent they didn't consent
to you filming them and knowing that
of course they're later on it'll be like
i guess put it in whatever i've said
that before
he says oh i asked her for consent the
next day it's like bro you're supposed
to act sick for consent
when she arrives not how it works and
once uh it's just so frustrating
but but i think what you're alleging is
that he asked people to get alcohol for
the girls
then that makes him like pretty much
fully guilty
fully guilty of knowing what's happening
of course
by him as it was reported the next day
i got consent to post the video even
though i got the consent to post that
video so by the way what he's doing is
basically
still leaving it all on dom by saying
this is something that happened with dom
i we got consent the next day but he's
skipping over really the horrible
allegations which is that
someone went and got alcohol under his
direction
yeah okay i also should know that i know
this for a fact
when filming drunk people right like you
have to say
like let's say let's say like okay so
like obviously reality shows and stuff
like that they sign something that says
like we're going to be consuming alcohol
you can film us okay they sign that
right
okay now i was in a situation where i
was in this on this porn set i was i was
just an extra i wasn't
in the porn it was called horny birds or
something like that i was in the porn
they gave all this alcohol including my
sister who was under the age of 21.
at the end of it they all before we got
paid they had to say okay say you
you had no alcohol no drugs during the
filming of this like you have to have
them say that in order for them to
consent
which was such a lie and i told my
sister we could do them because you're
underage because it was such a bad
experience
but it was like a lie and we did it
because we wanted to get paid or
whatever but like you
i'm sure he didn't have that footage of
them saying like yep i didn't have
alcohol like if you had to if you filmed
someone drunk which he did with these
girls
like you have to have the consent of
them saying either prior saying we're
going to be drunk and you're going to
film us
or after saying we didn't drink or do i
know this like it's happened to be
right situation consent in ndas and
consent forms are really tricky
illegally because
if you can prove that it was like of
course
uh um permission like the girl says
in her in the inside record that she was
still drunk when she woke up and didn't
even remember what happened yeah so
can't give consent then the next day
either
and by the way ndas don't hold water if
something illegal happens too oh my god
yeah i hate that too it's like you can
if
something's the truth and it's like a
cry like if you were you know a soldier
or whatever like you can say it
i should have never posted it and i
what i understand now and i didn't
understand before but again
like you received the text message from
hannah
six months later
and then removed it i guess that makes
sense it was when i did my video oh she
said she had said to dom like i saw
trisha's video
and like i don't feel comfortable having
my stuff out there like it was when i
did mine
that same time when i think of the group
or is that
she sent that text because she felt like
she had to
not because she wanted to and that's
[ __ ] up
and i'm sorry once you look that's good
it's good to hear right yeah and i'm
trying to be i'm trying to give him
you know points where where he where you
can get them
i just wish this like would have waited
it just all seemed so like if this was
how he feels in like six months or
whatever like he should have made this
video it's just like two it's like you
didn't feel this way you tried
to not even have the article come out so
i was like he should if he put this
video out
instead of his first apology and wasn't
spending all of his time trying to
keep the earth from coming out and
attacking everyone then we'd probably be
looking at this with a lot different uh
perspective just basically before the
sponsorships pulled out like
yeah and he probably saved himself
because he was desperate i think he was
avoiding it desperately because he
he suspected that a lot of sponsors
would pull out
if he acknowledged it happens so now he
has nothing to lose right
later reached out a couple months later
to take the video down i immediately
took it down
and i want to apologize to her and her
friends
forever putting them in an environment
that i enabled
that made them feel like their safety
and values were compromised i'm
so sorry i was completely disconnected
from the fact that when people were
invited to film videos with us
especially videos that relied on shock
for views or whatever it was that i was
creating an unfair power dynamic i did
not know this before
it was you're saying i mean and and i
agree that that's kind of like
a little naive like you i mean he knew
he
loved having power over people that way
he would just throw money at people
i mean he does this with his friends
with strangers like he you know
and your growth wait let me go back
because i remember
i wanted to say something about it and i
want to apologize
to her and her friends forever putting
them in an environment
that i enabled that made them feel like
their
safety and values were compromised i
mean that's good he's saying he's
admitting that he enabled that situation
you say okay which is good but i think
people are glossing over what it really
means is that he enabled this
attack to happen right like i think he
could
provide them with compensation or
something you know this guy's got money
if you
obviously money speaks for him once his
money was taken away that's when he knew
some [ __ ] went down
and it helped so many people especially
people like seth who was like struggling
with his like casting company and like
these girls yeah
i'm not mentioning seth right okay so
these girls in particular like not that
they're asking for money or something
but at least like compensate them for
some trauma or something like that you
you profit it off with them give them
some of that money or something
you know like they're college girls or
whatever it's like
and they they're not getting any money
off this but you can i i think that's
i know that's like admitting guilt or
whatever but like for me i always he
just said mid kill
so then you know that was good though he
said
he did say that i
enabled the situation that was good i'm
so sorry i was completely disconnected
from the fact that when people were
invited to film videos with us
especially videos that relied on shock
for views or whatever it was that i was
creating an unfair power dynamic i did
not know this before it was completely
wrong and i wish i was more responsible
and i wish i was more aware at the time
and
i'm so sorry i missed that i didn't know
what was going on in that room
and i should have been i should have
been there and i should have been making
sure that everybody involved
was was taken care of and wasn't
uncomfortable
again i think he kind of missed the
point there by saying i should have been
in the room
it's like no you shouldn't have put dom
who you already knew
was and a predator
right after the vidcon thing you
shouldn't you which you is
something that you continue to do is put
girls in a position to be assaulted by
your friend yeah when he platforms dom
they want to meet you david they want to
obviously they want to be in david's
vlogs that's what that's what all these
girls messages say they want to meet
david even on tick tock i see all these
girls saying oh he said i can meet david
if i came to the apartment like
you're giving him this platform because
you're showcasing the girls that come
home with dom
and it's gross you enabled all of it
multiple times it's not one twice
so many times but but
i he is saying something good and that
he's saying i'm responsible for what
happens there
which is right i don't want to use
buzzwords to try to justify this or
explain this
but all i can say is people felt like
they had to be silent for the sake of my
video and that's not right
and it's [ __ ] up and i'm sorry i also
want to acknowledge the women that spoke
out against dom in 2018
i'm talking about ally and then i'm
talking about other girls that
address their problems probably which
other girls
and all the other girls that express
their concerns privately
like holy [ __ ] bro i mean i like that
he's saying people's names i think
that's
dude they did that girl ali so [ __ ]
dirty oh yeah i stuck up for her a while
oh
yeah that yeah they it was awful and
then the fact that they kept like
showing she actually made a statement
here i'll read it i have it yeah she
don't accept his apology either is he
apologizing to her i don't even know if
he did he didn't apologize to me
i never gave you consent for anything i
told him too act like you don't know
well here she said so this is the girl
who was groped by don at vidcon in 2000
oh yeah she got the year wrong
too i was like i thought that was 2017.
um
and they and and then dom was like
basically was like she's kind of lying
but
anyway i'm sorry and david left the
famous comment saying
i hey good job buddy it's easy to be an
idiot
no it's hard to apologize he's like he
goes that's kind of not the truth but it
is the truth
like what so anyway she just tweeted
this in response to david's apology to
her she said
friendly reminder that my dom video was
in 2017 not 2018
don't know if this wasn't on a mistake
or trying to shorten the amount of time
he continued to platform him afterwards
i have mixed feelings on david dobrik's
apology
and himself because dom lied in his for
in his four years ago
to say whatever would look nice for the
camera and never privately reach
out to anyone even though he said he did
it for pr
i hope david will handle things
differently
so well david wasn't directly involved
with that one though right i'm not
saying it's like right but he didn't
film it or did he film no this was off
camera
this was like which is which makes it
like
way worse because every this whole thing
is like oh dom is playing this character
he's like no he's doing this off camera
that's such a [ __ ] like jason would
always say that too he's like we're
playing characters for david's like
movie i'm like this isn't a movie he's
not quentin tarantino like you guys are
just
a vlog bro they would all say that when
the something happened he's like
where can we if an actor did this in a
movie you wouldn't get mad at him for
kissing someone
not a pre-scripted blog that was like
i'm gonna get my old phone because like
the text messages from these people are
insane because i remember that too he's
like it's a movie i'm like
be honest do i look better like this oh
my god
you look or like this
kind of gives a vibe you have a nice
head shape
i do yeah thank you it's not deformed
kinda like a poodle too thank you so
much are you gonna dye it pink no i'm
cutting it all off
i'm over it okay let's watch privately
or publicly
i'm sorry i didn't listen to you guys i
am sorry
that i that i took dom's word um
for what happened those in those certain
situations and i didn't believe you
and not only did i not believe you but i
made a joke of of what kind of a person
dom was
because i couldn't wrap my head around a
childhood friend
of mine doing this to people and
actually hurting people and
and i'm sorry for that so at which point
between
the 2007 vidcon video and the scores of
other women that reached out to you
privately
that you refused to believe that your
childhood friend was capable of doing
that
wow i want to apologize to the thousands
of women who have reached out to me
privately
i think david's just uh disappointed
not mad not mad just never mad
not only did i discredit you at me but i
platformed dom
and not only did i platform down but i
platformed the subject of sex
in a negative way where i made jokes
about it and
i reinforced that kind of behavior and
i'm so
sorry and i really let not only you down
but a lot of people down a lot of people
that watch me
i mean again you could say too late too
little too late but i think he makes a
good point
because i think what's really damaging
is how he normalized dom
as like hey just your friendly
neighborhood predator
and like this kind of [ __ ] that they
regularly portrayed as like just
fun-loving [ __ ]
is is basically just grooming an entire
generation of kids i'm gonna give this
comment to the insider when this article
came out like hey i'm really sorry this
happened rather that his lawyer said
don't put him in the article otherwise
we're gonna threaten to sue you
i agree like i don't it's so it's so not
real the timing casts
a very cynical light on the entire video
i don't like i don't buy it at all this
was last week maybe because yeah
maybe he hasn't posted vlogs like things
change but no
everybody loved alfredo's cameo oh they
saw him
yeah i like him the best don't say that
about shredder do they know
my dog barks when they bark in the show
hi i love you
but he's just so loving the other one
always tries to bite me and shredders
how dare you here you want to hold it
off yeah
i love it come here you want to come up
come here sweetie i love shredder
i love shredder all right let's continue
a little eye bleach oh my god he's so
cute okay
okay here we go my friends and family
for that i made the decision to no
longer film with dom
in 2019 and i'm not saying my content
has been brilliant since then
but that's when i first started taking
into account
the power dynamic and he says he stopped
filming with dom
in 2019 cut to
um this one was pretty disturbing this
video was
on dom's channel as recently as last
night we ripped it because i knew that
they were going to take this down but it
was up wait what did they take down
this video but it was up since this
morning or last night
also do you think he should have been
holding maybe a puppy in this video
maybe that would have maybe scored some
points
i'm looking at this puppy now and i'm
like oh i'm gonna keep him for all my
opponents you're like i forgive you for
everything
right that he should have been having
like a little bit alfredo's alfredo
honestly is the sweetest dog ever no he
is like dogs don't usually like me but
he always comes up and like
he needs a shower you smell bad he's a
stinky boy really
yeah no you don't smell them thank you
for the kisses
so anyway all right you guys are
distracting me alfredo you sweet ass
cute [ __ ] sorry
um so he says that he discontinued his
relationship with dom
in 2019 but
here he is in 20 march of 20
oh this is unavailable because i have
the backup of course of course we have
the backup
now this video this last night what's
going on
just last night
wait what is this what is this response
you sent me who's this from
what my response to david's apology oh
um i guess seth sent you a statement oh
seth sent me a statement
yeah oh when i wanted to vet it first
but it just got sent
you weren't supposed to see that yet oh
he wanted to read it before i read it
i'll let you read it first can we read
it
but yeah i'll let dan read it first just
to make sure it's kosh but
because we're live you know what i mean
i just want to make sure it's all good
because we ordered the pizza there's
there's certain uh protocols when you're
live
that are different when you're
pre-recording yeah then boxing's not
cool
um okay interesting
so this was uploaded which i'll show you
the proof here what
are we going to say i think do i have
any breaking news no
yeah that's a good question so this was
called epic vlog squad party
march 2020. like
10 days before the pandemic and not only
that
the context of the video makes it even
worse watch this
y'all dirty down here i got a huge
announcement for y'all i'm officially
going on tour
the dirty and dangerous tour first stop
is usc
kappa sig robot tear it up tonight guys
comment down below what college
so he's promoting his i don't know what
he's like going and
throwing parties which is basically his
sh
world tour party i totally i'm assuming
it's like a frat party too
okay i told this is totally bringing
back memories i totally blocked out for
my time in the vlog squad
jason dom david and like zayn or whoever
they would go out to usc every weekend
and like crash parties and like dom and
jason would dress up as girls it's in
the vlogs
like they would dress up as girls to get
into like sororities and get where like
girls are like changing and stuff like
that like
and we wouldn't i stopped going i went
twice and i was so miserable they would
just go to like frat parties just trying
to like
find girls that were drunk and so i just
remember this at usc they would go ufc
all the time it's in the vlogs like
jason like streaked in his underwear
down usc frat road
jason man [ __ ] loves exposing himself
he's just i'm like nobody was and jonah
would do it too him and jonah what are
people jason's age supposed to be doing
i don't know watch like the bachelor or
something like me
yeah and you're like 10 years younger
than him chill out just have a seat
i don't know i don't know but anyway
this is important
so this is again march
march 1st 2020 they're helping him
promote his
world tour s a party
what fraternity i should come to if you
want me to come to fraternity and book
me
hit me up in the dms on instagram or you
can email me can you imagine like wow
what a party
let's turn up tonight yeah i'm dirty
down we're at usc
we're about to turn up tonight we're
about to respect women and robota
study hard we're about to respect women
and wink wink
you know who i am you know what i'm
saying come turn up with a boy
[Applause]
literally who cares about bomb nobody
everybody party
david's there you can just mute it
todd yeah todd's there
that's not clear that todd is there um
madison beer with dom i don't know if
she knows all this so i'm not gonna
natalie's there zane is there
madison beer by the way no she was in
that bit with tana and jason that i
didn't like the weekday before she knows
here he is talking about oh what what
here they have subtitles let me actually
read what they're saying
what's with everyone with the tooth oh
oh my god but this is like a huge cosign
of
where you know dom is going to be
regularly doing this to women
this is like his perfect you smell like
fruit
i smell like frat okay whatever what's
with everyone's whatever
40 cameras i mean david's there 20 20.
insane that's matt king in the back oh
look at your boy scotty
not a bad bone in his body would never
do anything we love you
and they also try and say they never
hung out with dom like this half of the
vlog
oh we never went to dub scott said oh i
never hung out with dom i never went to
his apartment
you're literally at his event like what
a stupid idiot
zayn multiple videos of him groping a
woman's breasts without their permission
kissing people without their permission
it muted it because there's like you
know copyrighted music whatever
anyway they're all there i i i don't
know if like jeff was i don't think i
saw jeff
or yeah i don't think jeff like i said
has always been kind of like
not as slimy as these other oh there's
jeff oh [ __ ]
she spoke too soon jeff's there shoot i
was trying to defend him
yeah ugh this is so embarrassing these
people are not like young either so once
again
how about that you're right like they're
out of yeah
it's a usc now once again a reminder
david who sever ties with don because he
knew he was such a danger to society
made a video promoting dom's world
essay tour college campus essay tour
in march of 2020. okay
and they deleted that video this morning
they deleted it this morning or last
night
wow with peace and love oops
oops and what influence i had on people
that i was filming let me back that up
just so you now can look at it with the
proper context not only you down but a
lot of people down a lot of people that
watch me and
my friends and family for that i made
the decision to no longer film with dom
in 2019 so i'm not saying
my content has been brilliant since then
well that's when i
what kind of lawyers there he made the
decision not to film
with don he's not filming with
i know i'm just saying like dude it's
even worse he's going to his event
and helping him promote it right like
what if i broke this chair alive i
almost did i heard it kind of crap
i oh i cracked a chair in a photo she
wants anybody twice i cracked a chair
hopefully i won't do it live
you broken two chairs a cheesecake
factory in my photos you broke a cherry
cheesecake factory
bro was it embarrassing yeah it was a
high chair that's why i never set the
high tables anymore because i'm like so
traumatized
i only said at booths that's crazy
yeah how much it was the one in terminal
was it a chair issue or
like a you issue i was like 140 pounds
oh you oh
so it was a cherish yeah but i still
felt fat because i was right you don't
ever break a chair yeah i was so
embarrassed
oh my god yeah anyways i almost did it
again i just heard the thing
i weigh more than you and my shirt's
fine i don't think you do we should
weigh
ourselves after this okay we'll have a
way off we started taking it into
pizza account the power dynamic
and what influence i had on people that
i was filming with but what i didn't do
is i didn't go back to any of these
women and apologize
i i kind of moved on and i learned from
it and i
grew from it but i didn't address the
situation with these women i'm not
talking publicly i'm saying even
privately i didn't reach out to any of
these people
and that breaks my heart knowing that
that i was
doing all this stuff and i was making
all this content wow well not only did
he not reach out and many times like you
and seth he threatened and
right right right or even to these girls
like why didn't you reach out before you
made this video
i wonder if he saw dom's epic response
to that text from hannah okay
i'm sure he did they share everything
with each other i'm sure he did okay
okay
there was people that were still really
hurt by what i mean before my content
shifted to be more responsible
he gave a little tear started and then
but he cut it away so it didn't feel too
much i thought that was a really good
in terms of the apology like technique
he teased the tears
but he didn't full out cry powerful
i thought that was a powerful sick
decision look how like he's just so
soulless he has no empathy for anyone he
doesn't feel bad about any of this like
you could just tell in his eyes
and you have to force them like that is
not real
i do think he feels bad i don't think he
does i really don't i really think he
i know he doesn't especially in my
situation he has no no guilt
no remorse i guarantee you
these people and that breaks my heart
knowing that
that i was doing all this stuff and i
was making all this content while there
was
people that were still really hurt by
what i made before my content
shifted to be more responsible and
positive i said and did things that were
really
offensive and i called them bad jokes
and i i can't even call them bad jokes
and it was
cowardly of me to say what's up
oh in my last apology that i missed
tomorrow
i'll wait i'll wait it's fine it's not
like we're live
no i'm kidding it's fine
move the trash put moses to where
what did i do it's your trash they need
to move
our car's blocking the trash well it's
your car rocking my trash
you can park on the street you know the
park in my driveway oh my god i can't
that's the rolls-royce driveway
okay okay all right because
it's [ __ ] gross and i'm sorry a lot
of people reached out to me wait he's i
wanted to analyze yeah
my content shifted to be more
responsible and positive
i said and did that you agree you i
remember you
saying that he's content has been better
of
of labrie center because the pandemic
hit and he couldn't vlog anything so yes
his content better because he hasn't
been posting vlogs
things that were really offensive and i
called them bad jokes and i
i can't even call them bad jokes and it
was cowardly of me to say
in my last apology that i missed the
mark um
because it's [ __ ] gross and i'm sorry
a lot of that's pretty good
i feel like he's been watching us
because i keep calling him gross i think
he's like yeah i was gross i i've never
heard it's
good i mean he said it was cowardly of
me to say i missed the mark that was
gross and i
and i think that's well stated i believe
i also called him a coward and gross so
so thank you for listening to being an
avid listener uh
you've been such a you've been such an
influence on him but the floor
between sitting on the floor and i
thought that was a good that was a good
next time there's not as many
edits no more cuts people reached out to
me
saying cancer culture is [ __ ] and
you need to fight back and you need to
call people out and i
don't agree with how this should be
taken at all
i wasn't sure why he said that
no because he's like so many people
think that all this is
[ __ ] right kind of being like and i
did and i did when i did two until
yesterday
until like everyone pulled out and i had
to quit my own app yeah
yeah probably not the best thing to
include in there but but i will say that
that
i mean that is a sentiment that his fans
were expressing a lot
all over social media that's good that's
good i think that's good that's a way of
trying to
like um speak to his own fans yeah
that's true because they kept harassing
seth and me and does everyone being like
you're upset
because the stan culture is just like so
so
i guess that's a that's a props moment
how would he fight back though like it's
also just
a moot point cause like what are you
gonna well he tries
yeah but his only defense was
discrediting me and saying church is
crazy but it's good here what else
defensively
oh seth oh look seth wanted to you gross
he's speaking directly to his fans in
this regard and saying this is not the
right
reaction so props to david i think when
there is a crisis
there's a serious opportunity to correct
yourself
to learn and improve and to make sure
those mistakes don't happen again
and that's what is so important to hold
yourself accountable and i think with
this situation
unrelated why are you laughing dan
there's a lot of comments today yeah
read the comments
it said that keemstar texted him that
keemstar
oh yeah keemstar yeah that's who i
thought too because what keemstar when
this originally started happening
keemstar tweeted david
um don't let ethan win he's like don't
give in
i support you and don't let ethan win i
was like okay dude
changed his tune now yeah yeah keemstar
but that alone should say so much of how
awful all these people are if like
keemstar is coming around and like
philip defranco and all these people i
was like okay
philip defranco usually has the right
take on things yeah he's really he's
really upset now he's really angry
yeah let's not philip phillip usually
has has
you know good a good informed thing
should i apologize to him or no
we're done for what we're calling him
fat
i feel bad all right go ahead make an
apology
i do feel bad phillip i held animosity
towards you because of interactions with
your wife in 2014 who called me a [ __ ]
i
how that against you i'm changed i'm
better i'm not miserable and depressed
anymore
you're not fat if anything you're
skinnier than me so i am a big fat cow
and you're a skinny legend and i'm very
very sorry
and i'm glad that you are covering david
moore and it's not just a boys club
and um i do not have an apology to
keemstar other than we're cool please
don't come for me
what you're not apologizing you're cool
with keemstar
right can't we be cool we don't want
enemies okay fine we don't want enemies
liberate now
now's not the time to make enemies
frenemies
no i don't want to say from just not
enemies i'll be a frenemies with philip
not enemies with keem okay nothing with
keem
okay i will make a apology too to dave
to phillip
um no because i called him a coward
should i no i don't think she'll
probably do that i stand by that he
didn't say anything until we talk but he
did but thank you for
boom i just apologize i should have done
that
right that was below blow right but
everything else is cool we're cool
everyone's cool on the internet i'll be
cool let's everybody be cool
and i you know what like i'm cool with
everybody except for david and jason
and scott and dixie no no
they are they are hanging out james
charles and david the demilious sister
all right let's
finish this apology for christ's sake
look at and there's a lot i can learn
from but there's
a lot of mistakes that i made and i'm
sorry for that i'm sorry
for everybody i've let down i'm sorry to
my family
and i'm sorry to my friends that i've
embarrassed and that this won't happen
again
i'm going to take a short break from all
the social media stuff because
i realize there's a serious lack of
infrastructure
when i make any kind of content and i
want to be able to have
a place of checks and balances i want to
have hr and i want to be able
um to have people communicate discomfort
and kind of
really i have a complaint
you do no i was like oh [ __ ] i was like
no i don't have hr then in that case
i have a i have um kind of kind of
i need employees jeff said he had 10
employees i don't have zero i was zero
employees
what does jeff's i mean i'm not familiar
with jeff but what is 10
people doing for jeff it's taking food
out of his mouth whatever it is
and i'm there i want employees
yeah yeah we have we have um we have
a makeshift hr yeah
thank you this is a good thing he's
saying because i think one of the
biggest problems with his vlogs
as we said is that when you are dealing
with big
production shoots on big uh
professional shoots you have the checks
and balances you have
the safety people you have the lawyers
well clearly the safety people aren't
there
jeff's eye i kind of say this or no
because there's a video online
not that i'm not encouraging people to
watch it but like he clearly doesn't
have safety issues with anyone
like what video online the jeff incident
that there's a video online of jeff
what happened yeah oh really yeah it was
that exfact gator thing and
excavator yeah i didn't watch it and
people were saying don't watch it it's
like really graphic but like
why are they all covering this up like
where's your safety people for these big
productions
jeff was injured during a david blog i
mean
oh logically it was for a david vlog it
was on video saw the video i saw a video
but it was you know
we don't know for sure that david was
involved so we should just be careful
about it well he definitely was on that
trip
and i it was shown that like todd was
there like people jumped in
after him so like right okay well fair
enough it wasn't maybe david's footage
but david was there and
regardless like why did jeff be he came
for me with so many personal things and
then i asked him about his eye which he
himself complained about i was like oh
what happened to him he's like
i want to talk about it's like don't
come for me and all my issues that jason
told you if you're not going to talk
about your personal issues
if he's having a big production he's
going to get an hr look into getting
safety
that's all i'm saying because it's crazy
jonah also had a motorcycle accident
going over a pool a year before i joined
the group and he like cracked his head
open and went to the hospital and kept
that hush-hush too
like get a safety person guy like you
have the money
that this is a really important thing
you can't continue the way you're doing
and the stuff you're doing without
having oversight and checks and balances
so that's a good thing he acknowledges
in a way that's that's comfortable too
late for jeff unfortunately
if what you're saying is true i hope he
covered jeffersonville or whoever did i
hope
better be getting a fat [ __ ] solo man
because like honestly i do feel like
jeff he said he was on medication
i feel like there is something maybe
wrong with him i feel horrible for the
the the injury jeff uh uh
that's what happened definitely i think
there's maybe something cause that's a
different jeff like you know
from the videos from what i knew like
it's a very different jeff like
i don't know i feel like i don't know i
don't i'm not saying like brain damage
i'm not saying that i'm just saying like
it's a different
he's a different one he definitely took
a hardcore
injury that's for sure but let's let's
let's not
speculate about jeff's injuries and
let's finish this video
yeah and where they don't feel like
their emotions
or what they're doing or or how their
acting is compromised
it doesn't feel right to go back to
posting like i have been and it also
doesn't feel right
to go dark because i love what i do but
i think it is important
to show that change is possible and that
i'm learning maybe even forgiveness is
possible i want to use this opportunity
to step up and on my mistakes and like i
said before i've never done
apology the right way and i'm sure i'm
gonna look back at this and i'm
i'm gonna be pissed at some things that
i didn't say or i wish i could have
added more
um but this is this is my beginning to
that and
and i'm sorry for everybody that i hurt
i also wanna add that i'm making myself
available to anyone that wants to reach
out that i've hurt in the past yeah i
love that i might i got lots of time
i will no longer be blocking your
numbers go ahead and reach out to me
i'm so cute should i try and call him
see if he answers call him right now
live
would you talk to him no i wouldn't so
why would you call him yeah i know i
don't know just to see if he didn't make
himself available
i feel like you could have a a
productive conversation absolutely not
because you have a lot of
trauma and then you you hold a lot of
resentment that i
wonder if you would be able to resolve
yeah it's a lot it's a lot of trauma
that i dealt with through therapy and i
was able to resolve it through myself
and there's no resolution i'm going to
get from david losing sponsors and now
being like
i'm sorry just like jason calling me no
i've been getting them to talk to me for
a year and a half i begged them
i showed up to jason's house i made
videos saying please i'm so sorry i did
this to the group
none of them acknowledging me jason
constantly telling me oh there no one
can acknowledge you no one's gonna talk
to you like they were
they shut they they mocked me and when i
was at coachella todd was pissed trying
to knock the door down saying
like kick her ass like all this crazy
[ __ ] like they mocked me and ridiculed
me
for years when i was going through like
the worst year of my life like i've
never once tried to kill myself i never
once tried to go to mental hospital and
spiral and spiral spiral and they kept
triggering and triggering and triggering
it and it was such
[ __ ] it was such [ __ ] and this
is [ __ ] because he's losing sponsors
and you know what i will say i'm happy
that he is because it's so
[ __ ] annoying having to deal with
someone who gets away with [ __ ] and like
and he's
so no remorse i tried i tried reaching
out to him for a year and a half there's
zero remorse i do not believe he's
changed
in a week from him trying to discredit
me because i have a mental illness i
think he's full of [ __ ]
i think he's just the worst and i think
he lost money and that's the only reason
he's crying that's why i'm saying donate
money to show that you don't care about
money that it wasn't just about the
sponsors living donate it you have the
money donate some
put it towards mental health put it
towards jeff what exactly said that too
oh mental people with mental illness
should be given a platform to speak like
[ __ ] off donate your [ __ ]
get educated learn about that [ __ ] i
think you have a mental illness you have
something wrong with you look at that
face your soul is behind those eyes
he's a soulless little chipmunk and i
don't like a soulless little [ __ ]
mom okay that was me not the chipmunk
the soul is part though
the soul is mean too that's what he is
look at his eyes
there's there's no soul oh oh
oh i thought you were having a heart
attack for real bring it so they can see
what i just said i just storm off again
i'm so mad
because just show it we don't have to
eat it right now yeah i just had a
is there a phone number on it i just had
a vietnam flashback of moses walking
down the stairs with the pizza
did you have to expect us to be having
like a full-fledged like moment look how
smart i am
i'm so smart with domino's knowing that
there's a phone number there that's what
i said turn it to us because i knew
there was one
oh dude you are experiencing i know
that's right let's let's
see okay we're almost done we're almost
done okay okay oh thank you
last time i want to be able to to hear
and understand from yourselves and i'll
be reaching out on my own to some people
because i still have a lot of learning
to do and
i think when you talk to other people
especially about experiences like this
let's focus on the video let's eat it
upstairs i don't want to do a whole
mukbang
let's just let's start let's stay
focused the pizza one moving at the end
of celebration
it's got me like david apollo joy yeah
okay yeah let's focus but can we have
one at the end so people can see it
they get so butthurt while we don't show
them the food at the end everyone's like
why didn't you film because we're gonna
oh last time okay okay okay all right
everyone focusing
yeah okay um because i still have a lot
of learning to do and
i think when you talk to other people
especially about experiences like this
it um it really helps you see things in
a different way but yeah i'm sorry if
this video was all over the place i just
wanted to
sit and talk and ramble and and i
really truly hope that someone can take
something away from this experience that
another creator
can can take away from this and i know
it's it feels
and because i know how crazy it felt to
me that there was
some sort of toxicity or something hello
hello
hello yes
yeah we're okay i know i've probably
just i keep getting swatted so
so but but everything yeah everything's
just fine over here thanks for calling
okay okay thank you bye
what is that we just got swatted
but less intense it's been happening so
much now
that they just call me and be like are
you okay we just got a call
because then if i don't answer they have
to come so they say is everything okay
and i say yes
i know we keep we keep getting yeah that
was the police you're so nonchalant
about it
yeah well i'm just trying to be calm
about it but yeah obviously it's
annoying
it's happening like a lot
but but you know at least now it's like
cool they call me immediately and if i
don't answer they come
but if i catch it in time and say like
hey it's okay i know i've been swatting
then they say okay good everything's
okay yeah i put my name on that list too
good job inside yeah people always tried
to 515 after i got 5150 i always get
wellness checks police would show up and
be like we got reports that you're
trying to offer yourself and i was
totally fine and i was like [ __ ] up
yeah were they doing because they were
concerned or they're doing the [ __ ] with
you
no tap [ __ ] with
[Music]
well they thought if they call that i'm
taken away to a mental hospital that's
like not how it works they ask like
they see if you're trying to commit
suicide well joke's on you you're not
gonna ruin my pizza party [ __ ]
i keep saying whoever is doing this the
last person who did this literally is in
jail right now so
i don't know why investigate it it's not
like
right what yeah it's not worth it to
whoever's doing it i guarantee it
i knew so i get i always i never answer
unknown numbers but i could tell
when i get this specific number that i
know it's the police i was like i have
to answer this
oh i was like i'm just taking a phone
call no
yeah yeah no trust me if i didn't take
the call it'd be
we would regret it that'd be so scary
yeah anyway let's continue sort of power
dynamic in my friend group
but really just take the moment
especially when creating content that
you're trying to get
viewership out of or you're trying to
get laughs out of like really take a
moment
and and look at where the jokes end and
where the feelings begin
because i think that's so incredibly
important
okay he acts like it's some kind of like
large issue happening on youtube he's
like i'm pretty sure it's not
it's pretty much just you david if
another creator can learn like nobody
else is doing this
like look i think i do think there's
some part of him
it's like when you lose everything then
i feel like
it's like a rock bottom situation it's
like then you can actually
see things clear for what it is so i
don't i do think there
is some genuine remorse here even though
the timing and everything
is makes it all super suspicious but
it's like it's that rock bottom nothing
to lose and then he's like oh [ __ ]
you know right he was like untouchable
for so long i feel
yeah um yeah i don't think it's
genuine i think he's thinking like oh i
should probably like
reevaluate but should i read seth's
statement
dan um
dan's eating pizza okay
here's seth's statement he says my
response to david's apology
david producing conspired with jason to
manipulate me
and essay me and title it a prank jason
hasn't apologized david david hasn't
personally apologized
and not just for missing the mark but
then bragging about it to teach
generations of kids
that his behavior was somehow all right
and even attempted to silence and
discredit me
it's truly a s it truly is sickening
companies were funding it and viewers
were interacting with the videos and
making millions of dollars off of other
people's lifelong trauma
what you permit you promote stop
permitting
what you permit you promote stop
permitting it
branch should focus on micro creators
who are truly making a difference within
the communities
and who are really an example of values
these companies stand by
the influencer is
the answer is a.i influencers
see on some [ __ ] like what is he talking
about dan i
think he i mean ai influencers are a
thing
what is that he's saying the answer is
ai influencers
ai influencers what is it well those are
like
those fake like computer generated
influencers instead of real people
well maybe that's what we need to go to
that's the answer i guess that's what
he's saying i want to [ __ ] keep
working seth
the answer is but then he says the
answer is choosing humanity
those with common courtesy kindness and
love for all i also would like to thank
all the drama channels
insider and other press outlets trisha
and h3h3 for bringing these problems to
life
there you have it so he's basically
saying they haven't apologized to him
they're basically saying like we're
apologizing to everyone we made wrong
yeah and i'm sure and they i noticed
they made like a conscious effort almost
to
oh abe saying he means not all okay
whatever
not all influencers and whatever it does
i get the it piss me off that like that
did get
glossed over ces thing like jason and
david who are directly involved with
that not dom not anyone else
like how it got glossed over maybe
huh no what did i do i don't think so
i think it's i think
beautiful
we finally ate pizza together let this
be the last david dobrik video
we ever make i
yeah because we do look like those
obsessive drama channels that make like
four
i like i'm so fine we're just going to
do our eating competition next week or
no we're doing satisfied you know i'll
just like have that would be the title
by the way did i mention the thumbnail
for yesterday people like it looks like
trisha is laughing at the demise of the
vlog
that thumbnail we posed for was the
original title was trisha takes over
because it was my episode so i'm
laughing so i'm like ha ha i'm taking
over
not just down ball cause people in the
comments were saying that i always look
like i was like laughing
i felt but you are no the jefferson in
particular was really hard on me because
i was just like oh this is just like
really painful because again i don't
think he's like as slimy as like
david and jason and jason not saying
anything cowardly like all of them it's
just a lot you know
can you send that heart back to jason
now that he's probably seen this
when do you want to talk send it from me
send it for me say like this starts from
ethan
it's such [ __ ] apologize to that
well me you could apologize me but
all right and so and
this david dobrik saga i see you
tomorrow i'm talking about dave
again yeah well
you've been a long week for me man it's
only tuesday
all right thank you guys for watching
another emergency episode of frenemies
does anyone still on do we lose
followers or do we gain them how many
people watching
uh it says 162 000
that's a lot we could sell out like
what is that like you think people would
pay to watch to see pizza
at like the greek i used to do that on
my tour i used to do it i just
like eat pizza on stage it's so cringy
you could like see trisha eating people
like were you just quietly eating no i
was like answering questions
why do you eat pizza yeah why it was my
q a and they wanted to see me like a
live mukbang
it was full-screen it was full screen's
idea not mine it was a little cringe my
second tour was really good i did all my
music but the first door was very crazy
wouldn't it be kind of epic to
sell out the greek and just silently eat
pizza
that's what we should do paint right the
greek that's very andy kaufman
when he read the great gatsby at those
colleges more entertaining than pizza
you do
i don't know about that maybe not all
right guys
wait is that it that's it so
what do you rate it out of 10 david's
apology
like okay so
like i said that triggered you on face
value like boom here's an apology it's a
good apology
but in the context of everything it
feels less genuine
i'm not gonna rate it i think he's
i hope and i hope that this is the
beginning of him really
caring and trying to make amends for
everything i say fire your pr person
fire natalie you and jason need to
apologize to seth and maybe disassociate
for a little while
and um maybe uh
go to the no hate bullying tour learn
some things from dixie and maybe
maybe he should sit in on the yeah what
i'm saying like maybe take some lessons
from them
keep going on the tour dixie has some
lessons for you dixie knows
i stand dixie emilia we're now we are
standing next to me on this podcast
really yeah what happened um she's on
the no bullying tour
oh my gosh they didn't get the memo the
police are here
all right i gotta go talk to the police
bye guys i'm gonna go talk to the police
thanks for watching
[Music]
yeah we'll bring it up wait trisha say
bye oh
thanks for watching with peace and love
and um don't send any hate anybody we
talked about we'll see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
so
you